hey guys it's inka i still have a big
forehead my eyes are down here welcome
back to another round of trendy versus
traditional i will be representing
trendy i will be making a very
traditional dish you read out of your
comments you read all of them and there
is a lot of weird stuff in there one of
the comments that we kept on seeing was
burgers i love burgers i have also never
made a burger in my life confidence
boost i'm feeling good that traditional
might take this one i have some big
ideas today that i will try and make
happen i take back what i said about
being confident you're cooking first
good luck
thanks have a great time cooking a nice
burger i can't wait to try it okay so
burgers i think i could have taken this
in a lot of different directions but
what really caught my eye was the ramen
burger it was actually really popular a
while back it became this huge
phenomenon i love ramen and i love
burgers so ramen burger together is one
just seems like a really cool idea i
will at least try to make it taste as
good as possible welcome to
traditional burger land there's not
going to be a lot of wild stuff going on
we're just making a burger simplicity is
key here this is a table full of
boringness but when they all come
together something really special we
should probably
make the buns this is actually the ramen
that the og
ramen burger master uses folks let's
start with buns to start we're going to
toast the buns just trying to loosen it
up a little bit we're actually going to
keep it undercooked because we have to
pan fry them later maybe 30 seconds
would be enough
go 30. that pan is heating up a little
bit i don't think we need any fats in
there we're just toasting that so once
we take these out we're gonna put them
in this mold right away no eggs or
anything because i don't want it to be
too custardy instead this oops hold on
30 seconds take it out the starchiness
of the noodles itself will actually help
it clump together before you even start
to come for me in the comments the
produce is washed delete the comment
that you have typed out this is washed
we're not going to show it on camera
enough so we're just going to peel off a
couple
it's not washed uh
go ahead and re-type it in give me five
seconds i'm a joke here are the
half-cooked nudes
gonna
they're nudes but here are the
half-cooked noodles to put half of this
in here to shape our first bun you can
see that it's kind of sticky that's good
that's the starch got the lettuce
washed
i like the taste of the sticker i'm
really uh falling apart here guys we're
gonna go ahead and save that sticker for
later that's the first one fold this
together in saran wrap like this and
then do the same thing i'm gonna wash
this on camera cause not gonna be taken
for a full anymore as i'm prepping the
toppings here i think a big part of
burgers but really any like sandwich
vessel in particular are ratios you
don't want to like take a bite of a
tomato you want to take a bite of a
burger and all its friends so that's
what i'm going to aim for here today
just like little thin pieces once you
put it in here you need to find
something to really press it down i'm
using my hands right now but i'm going
to find something to put on top of this
by the way
can we talk about the bun real good
looking toast on there you want it to
stand up to the juice so we've got some
pretty good juice defense here i happen
to have a pickle jar that i stole from
chris i'll return it to chris later but
sort of like that so it can help form
that shape and then we're now going to
put this in the refrigerator we're going
to toss some bacon in that's also going
on the burger we don't need a ton of
bacon this isn't a bacon sandwich while
the noodles are chilling in the fridge
there's a couple more things we could
work on like toppings and sauce
caramelized onions could be a good touch
because that's actually what the
original ramen burger does all i have to
do is chop up this onion so i think
anything with bacon on it
will win bacon is
just a delicious treat and when you slap
it on to another delicious treat we're
talking success it's only so quiet
you'll notice there's three pieces of
bacon in here two for the burger
one for
the boy i need
sustenance to get through this turn this
on pour some oil in there oh i love this
sound i guess we'll cut an onion too
we're gonna keep it pretty true to like
a burger you would order at a restaurant
just like a couple couple hoops couple
of onion hoops it's a really time
consuming process but i promise it will
be worth it it'll get this like caramel
color this sort of like jam-like
consistency which i'm thinking we'll be
mixing in with the sauce that we'll be
making later the only thing
worse than limp bacon
is dirty lettuce and i've already done
one of those things today and i will not
do another i made a mess already but
that's important when you're cooking
traditionally everything's a mess that
means you're doing it right i'm going to
pull two of these guys out put them on a
paper towel to get some of that grease
off this is going to take
a long while we don't actually have
enough power in this studio to have two
stovetops going at the same time i am
going to bring this into
the other kitchen and try to cook it
there the bacon grease that is in this
pan is going to be our fat when we cook
the burgers in the cast iron skillet and
i'm really excited for it let's work on
the sauce the sauce i'll be making is
actually sort of like a tare which is
the glaze or the dipping sauce that they
usually offer at like japanese barbecue
there's a couple of things that go in
there this liquid is a combination of
kombu and bonito flakes which is just
seaweed and some fish flakes that's kind
of the broth that i made earlier on
we're gonna pour a little bit of that in
there to give it some flavor soy sauce
sake sweet cooking wine sugar because
you want it to be sweeter garlic and
ginger there we go give that a good mix
we are actually gonna let this slowly
simmer until it becomes slightly
stickier and slightly thicker we've got
some toppings we've got our bacon now
it's just time to talk
patties i'm gonna ask my wife to please
turn off the video
the ring's coming off mostly because i
don't want e coli and other
meat germs onto my nice wedding ring we
simmered it for two hours but the actual
sauce that they put in the ramen burger
when i talked to chef keisel he told me
they take six hours to make that the
ramen is a novelty but the sauce is
where the magic really is which is why
i'm really putting a lot of effort into
this put a little bit of this into the
onions
so it gets immersed this
will be our
sauce with a condiment like this i think
just one is enough if you put a little
too much in there might get a little too
crazy meat 85
lean to
15
fat if the ratio is any more lean then
you're gonna start to get towards a
burger that isn't as juicy and succulent
the meat has been sitting out which is
nice you never want to put like ice cold
meat into a pan it's going to seize up
you want your meat to just
relax just eyeball your bun this patty
is 80 lean and 20 fat going for more fat
here because it's juicier there's really
no rubric to how big the patty has to be
i want mine to be kind of the same size
as the noodle buns we're gonna make a
little dent in the middle so that it
doesn't turn into this meat mountain i'm
putting a little like pothole in here
i'm not seasoning it yet i'm gonna
actually wait for it to cook first
before the patty goes into its hot
little bed we need to season the
ever-loving hell out of it
put a little bit of this
bacon grease into our pan here and she
goes
this is going in there oh my god look at
that sizzle it's getting my face once
you flip the burger that's when you put
the cheese on the cheese just gets melty
it's like a big cheese blanket that goes
around the burger the reason we're using
a cast iron is because it's a pan that
holds a lot of heat burgers done gonna
let it rest here you know what also is
cool about meat that when you go to flip
it it just comes right off that's how
you know it's we're good we're good to
go now that we've flipped what do you
think about that
two slices of cheese once we get to
around six minutes of this burger that's
when you whip out the
piste resistance little old thermometer
so we are at
where we want to be gonna go ahead and
take
this guy off just let it hang out here
now for the noodle buns
you're the ramen buns they're circular
beautiful hopefully they'll hold its
shape we're gonna pan fry these now and
sesame oil
i've earned myself a snack
i'm sorry inca but like bacon on a
burger
i'm gonna take these out now this one's
trying its best
that's one and that's two
and now for the cherry on top you know
how ramen usually is served with an egg
i was thinking a ramen burger could also
have an egg so
let's get cracking
i'm trying to not cook the egg yolk too
much because normally it's a soft boiled
egg that goes into the ramen while
that's cooking i'm going to glaze the
burger this is why i said we don't need
to season it it's going to get this
coating
oh
i did it i flipped it and
that is our egg fantastic we have all
our components ready i'm just going to
reset the table let's get to plating
where
are my pickles i'm returning to chris
later my inspiration today is just a
krabby patty whenever i see a krabby
patty on screen just like that's what a
burger looks like i'm gonna be very
careful here see i'm already
oh god
are you kidding me how does that happen
ketchup this is gonna be a disaster if
you thought the mustard was bad come on
oh my god what is happening right now
[Music]
that's what i wanted but
gordon ramsay i know you're watching
look away because that is
horrific plating it is time to assemble
[Music]
it's slightly messy but this is the
ramen burger i think that looks exactly
like a krabby patty it looks
so good it's so round oh i'm so happy
i'm gonna finish my bacon
i got a lot to clean up
oh
my god yours looks so good and there's
an egg on it and you put bacon in yours
i'm not feeling good about it i'm not
feeling great either this is such a good
looking burger i appreciate that this is
clearly the time-intensive flavor bomb
that it looks like we're gonna have our
friend vic come in and he is going to
tell us which burger he prefers the
traditional or the trendy so vic is
gonna give up to five points for the
look of the burger and five points for
the taste of the burger and in the
burger with the most points that's the
burger that wins wow look at this
i've had plenty of burgers in my day
trust me but i've never seen one like
this that one caught my eye right away
this is gorgeous too i'm ready
[Applause]
that looks nice that's a serious cross
section now the moment of truth
holy crap if you threw a ramen noodle
soup together i made it a burger yes
that's the idea that was really amazing
i'm gonna
i'm gonna move on to the next one before
i fill up this guy
get this guy a napkin here let's get to
this bat wow this one looks like real
classic stab into this bad boy it's that
juice though wow that's so good i can
smell it from here
a little power mustard on the bottom too
don't even get me started i think you
did a good job maybe a little bit more
cooking i would like it but still super
juicy cheese was a little bit thick oh
it was toasted on the bottom that makes
it good but nice for burger number one
looks solid four it's just very
beautiful you know very well constructed
to hear that butt and i'm sorry chris
ingersberger takes a cake i'm gonna give
inga's five on both the flavor and the
looks the moment i walked in here my eye
drew to that one it just looks complex
and awesome and i love ramen i think
inga is the winner for this challenge
you deserve
i have redeemed myself since last step
that ends
another episode
trendy versus traditional type in the
comments what you want to see next let's
do this
[Music]
you